[Musique]
ça donnait un oui et il tenait devant
tout ça je me demande ce que tu as bien
voulu préparer là en fait tout cas
encore un tour extraordinaire
ah bon oui j'ai été dans une cave j'ai
déboucher des bouteilles pour avoir les
bouchons tu vois effectivement beaucoup
de bouchons bien beaucoup de bouchons
bonsoir à tous et à tout son souffle
après soir comme on se fait un pli
tomate parce que là ils ont besoin de
suivre très attentivement je vois pas du
tout tu veux en venir les vingt-sept
demandent des explications
vas-y voilà bon pour un bouchon mais
n'importe lequel web en bouchon un
bouchon tu le pouce sur le bord du
goulot de cette bouteille qui a débouché
sur le bord du wild eyes il va tomber
tu vois il ne vient pas non pas
facilement non il alors tu vas à côté là
devant toi tu as un bouchon où il ya des
fourchettes qu'ils ont piqué ah oui
d'accord oui quoi le pose sur le bord du
boulot à temps je leur montre quand même
à vous êtes à un bouchon avec deux
simples fourchette n'est ce pas
extrêmement facile oui tout le monde
chez soi c'est pas compliqué alors
maintenant que c'est bien solide que
j'ai bien enfoncer qu'est-ce qu'il faut
faire alors tu le pouce sur le bord du
boulot tu vas voir tu vas repousse
bleues sur le bord du boulot encore du
boulot ça va se balancer parce que sans
tomber d'ailleurs on dit tu sais tu vas
les bouchons bouchon l'escarpolette
c'est sa porte
là tu es side by side gélifie le film
essaye de vider sa bouteille dans un
verre tu vas voir les bouchons ne tombe
pas que j'ai lu le soleil tourne fait ça
ça va pour marcher mais si tu crois mais
c'est obligatoire h prend des risques
aujourd'hui assez y ait un vainqueur et
gratuit ça s'est passé pas très commode
a essayé toute la nuit alors je peux y
aller as tu peux ah ben oui dit non
c'est un bâtisseur la regarde ça coule
la toque voilà voilà un choix c'est une
chose qui est amusante a fait c'est pas
compliqué c'est pas compliqué non et
puis beauvais ça ça fait toujours rire
oui s'amuse à la faveur quoi pouvait
faire ça tranquillement chez vous sans
le moindre problème c'est qu'on peut le
système mais tu sais qu'on peut faire
mieux un mois je crois qu'on préfère vue
parce que regardent fourche et une bonne
non pas non pas du tout tu vas chercher
les complications le regarde moi j'ai
pris le même système que le tien riz
c'est à dire simplement un bouchon et
avec deux fourchettes et j'ai planté
dans le bouchon une épingle eq la tête
en bas le regard et pourquoi tu veux
toujours me milliers c'est pour te
montrer quel artiste je suis regarde ce
travail que d'aucuns admis voilà
regardez-moi ça mais c'est pas
magnifique ça oui et alors tu peux le
secouer dans tous les sens le bouchon
tient toujours
watsa tourner nos photos qui va être
piquée avec vos règles pique pas ou
alors si tu avais pas d'arrêt j'irai pas
de soigner extraordinaire ça arrive
c'est as tu connais le système pourquoi
ça marche ça tu sais pourquoi ça le
bouchon reste toujours comme ça c'est de
la physique
c'est de la physique d'un vieux
principes de physique les centres de
gravité étant plus bas que le bouchon
lui même c'est très facile de le faire
tenir en équilibre voilà c'est tout
c'est un vieux principe d'équilibré
vous avez certainement vu sur un fil de
funambule avec une longue barre comme ça
et ça leur permet de bien se tenir sans
problème c'est à peu près la même chose
en valeur un problème c'est pas si
simple à leur piquer des fourchettes
dans les côtes l'eau mais n'ont pas eu
de fourchette plus grand quand je
trouvais ça cruel oui notre propre
besoin d'un oiseau se trouvait ce
problème oui donc tu rends sur un poulet
à la rigueur même port louis oui voilà
bon ben alors maintenant c'est fini un
alors tu quittes tu quittes c'était
mably ou j'attaque
ah bon je m'en moque je te pousse avec
mon bec me poussa réseaux mobiles à 3
violemment non non non sous contrat en
voyant pas que tu vas dans le jardin oui
enfin je marche avec une facilité 7 9
incroyable bompas beat dont bell bell
vous êtes prêts oui oui gérant cette
fois ci il ne faut pas qu'ils tombent
il ne faut pas qu'ils trouvent ça rit ça
ce n'était pas trop déçu c'est la soupe
à ce fut tellement nous allons tous les
trois très content et une petite
histoire et puis bon bah nous sommes des
objets ou des choses ou des unreal
différents mais nous avons tous les
trois un point commun ou alors
aujourd'hui tu sais ce que je suis non
tu ne sais pas non non je vais te le
dire je suis un avion un avion
supersonique je suis mettant le concorde
1 le nippo ligne numéro je ne sais 47
quelconque je transporte des passagers
de paris à new york ou à tokyo ou à
londres ou à montreuil est alors en
quelques heures
je vole à plus de 10000 m enfin je tu
vois je suis extraordinaire maintenant
alors bon bah si tu as des goûts plus
modestes page peut être aussi un petit
avion avec une hélice un petit moteur et
puis bon c'est comme tu veux tu as le
droit de choisir rêve un avion je t'ai
mis sur la voie au label rivale bell
pour moi je suis un mois là à moulins
comme hélas il n'y en a plus beaucoup en
france de ces moulins où les paysans à
porter leurs sacs de blé ont transformés
en sacs de farine a bien sûr ce n'était
pas très pratique
il fallait du vent pour les faire
marcher et je restais quelquefois en
panne pendant plusieurs jours en
attendant une bonne brise
maintenant avec les moulins electrical
a+ et en huile a enfin sauf quand il ya
des pannes de courant alors
[Musique]
c'est pas mal
voilà moi moi moi moi moi je suis un
très beau un très grand château je ne
veux pas faire de fausse modestie je
suis même moi je peux le dire je peux
dire un de ces merveilleux château de la
loire qui font l'admiration du monde
entier
oui je possède tout ce qui fait le
charme d'un château un parc
naturellement une pièce d'eau et puis
des bâtiments qui permettent de loger
mais très nombreux invités de les loger
de les nourrir de garer leurs voitures
et trois mois s'il y avait encore des
chevaux cela ne me gênerait pas du tout
voilà harris tard si tu trouves le point
commun alors là eh bien on pourra dire
que tu es un petit génie vous avez
trouvez vous même vous avez trouvé quel
point commun unis mais mes trois
compagnons c'est nous avons un avion
nous avons un moulin nous avons un
château et je verrai bien à la limite
entre le château et le moulin toit
pointu mais alors dans l'avion y'a pas
toi
vous avez trouvé vous savez déjà à temps
le moulin ça pourrait être une hélice
avec l'avion à hélices non il m'a dit
qu'il était aussi un avion à réaction
à moins à ce n'est pas comme moi je dit
d elle
mais on n'arriverait jamais on
n'arrivera jamais à 8 lors le beta mais
ça j'ai trouvé la gérait le château et
bien entendu des ailes au moulin c'est
ce que vous aviez trouvé
ah bah bravo c'est bien je fais un
public si bon bon bon port l'appel à
témoin une bille sont bons noms
d'oiseaux n'a pas ce que ça me
réconforte à la maintenance et pousse
mousse rigide à moi à boire debout soit
tu sais mon nom mon jeu de l'autre jour
alors oui oui oui oui mais alors cette
fois c'est beaucoup plus difficile à oui
oui oui comme comme l'autre jour un
qu'est ce que tu m'a préparé et ben
c'est un mot en dix lettres et 10
rebonds sam beaucoup plus difficile a
dit l'être en dix lettres alors la
première lettre à qu'est ce que tu as a
man jeudi lors de la première lettre est
un e e
hum hum aléas le e
voilà après tu fais huit petits prêts
comme viande l'autre sous les traits lui
alors et la dernière lettre c'est un peu
comme la première encore mary river
[Musique]
valley et y est pas facile allez j'y
vais oui alors qu'ils vont râler les
questions bien c'est un animal très
rapide
ben moi j'attaque ou c'est un animal un
animal bon bien énerve c'est un c'est un
gros animal le haut non non non donc ça
n'est pas pour qui oui non plus c'est un
gros animal quoi rire pendant une heure
tout con français mais est-ce que ça
vole un ânon non non ça vole pas est ce
que sa rampe
non non c'est un animal fier au oui/non
ces fiers oui oui oui
tu veut peut-être que je t'aime un petit
peu attends attends bas fonds je veux
bien parce que vous vous suivez vous
vous allez trouver moi pas l'âge alors
la jeune âge la quatrième lettre
oui la 4e les années 3,4 et ses 1ers à
herrère de 3,4 c'est sévère comme animal
ah non non non c'est non et plutôt frais
plutôt qua non à non non non pas commode
l'ennui c'est que personne ne peut
m'aider je me retrouve absolument trop
seul dans cette affaire là est ce que
c'est un animal de basse cour
non non non un animal dans la forêt ah
oui et oui oui oui un animal qui est c
est ce que c'était c'était que ça court
très vite
howie our très vite très très vieille
très vite avec un air ici est ce que est
ce que c'est un animal méchant au nom sa
gentille très genre est gentil trois
jours des amis à toi tu luttes oui oui
oui oui oui oui c'est utile
oui très utile oui rangeois potes c'est
bon je repousse moussaoui en cage avec
un noeud en eux à la fin ça a mûri je
pense à ça grimpe aux arbres là ça
grimpe d'arbres je peux dire que ça
grimpe au sahara
ah bah non ça peut pas aller ça finit
par un noeud sinon moi j'aurais dit et
tu rails et bah oui c'est aussi ça est
passé il a prouvé
enfin pouces moussu écureuils sacékripa
avec un noeud à la fin commenté chris
avec le relais bon c'est une femelle pas
du tout où cancre envoyons écureuils ça
s'écrit comment eux c'est r uni 2 l1
mais pas du tout bon mais c'est une
honte ça s'écrit pas comme ça regardez
comment ça s'écrit vous savez très bien
vous même enfin change mais tu es fou
enfin qu'est ce que c'est hui l voilà
hui elle pas elle
enfin pour ce monsieur non ça tu sais
faut revoir tonneaux crachent jeudi la
dernière fois c'est pas bien du tout je
suis pas content tu meures à tous les
coups je le savais je le savais pas tant
qu'il fallait permettre de zelda
écureuils mais j'ai oublié
je suis comme l'écureuil je vais chez
pas de mémoire
alors tu sais ils ont dit aux provisions
des noix des noisettes des graines de
toutes sortes et ils les cachent dans un
petit coin hein mais sans jamais s'en
sert jamais car il sait plus où sont ses
cachettes
alors il faut qu'ils recommencent à
chercher de la nourriture du danseur
c'est très fatigant d'être un écureuil
il le fait à chaque fois c'est vrai
chaque année font la bêtise
ah oui tu as raison de nous rappeler ça
c'est une chose très significative de
décrue je l'avais oublié merci osmosis à
toi tu te rattrape lab avec l'indien
abah abah ça fait plaisir
maintenant tu sais belle belle belle
belle elle adore chanter un abri j'ai
combien moi elle me charme
alors écoute cette chanson là tu veux tu
avoir y avoir comme le chant bien je
veux bien
[Musique]
j'ai très vite couverts de là
asseyez vous écoutez bien la nouvelle
vous étonnera je mets ma vie écoutez
bien avec john
[Musique]
boyce j'aime ont fui pour toujours avec
lui et à une coupe de champagne au
tricot wiimote ne comprends rien du tout
et j'ai justement ça ici tranquillement
c'est incroyable alors avec qui qui sait
ça du jeune travail peur tu vas tu vas
pas nous quitter belles belles surtout
pour john travolta allait bien sûr que
si une femme doit suivre son mari c'est
la loi quand tu vas là aux états unis
oui tu connais les états unis veut bien
sûr puisque scanner diane travail a
abondé c est sûr de toi là effectivement
mais a prévenu john travolta ville où
tout est lisse la gare journaliste selah
sue passionata ne se laisse j'ai visité
la ville à pied tranquillement admirant
au passage les autres types onu mans je
me revois devant la cathédrale un
chef-d'oeuvre de l'architecturé gothique
une voiture passe à john était au volant
il me ville figure aurait fait le coup
de foudre
elle coûte de change pas on n'aura non
merci non non non ça me pique le nez
puis ça me donne envie de dormir au jeu
sommet louis non j'ai encore des choses
à vous dire
un bonheur n'arrive jamais seul je
signais ce même jour un contrat fabuleux
bah je vais faire du cinéma à mes amis
vallat le bras je le garde sur mon coeur
ça c'est extraordinaire là
les états unis vraiment tu peux encore
me raconter de petites choses je ne le
ferai pas lire mon contrat n'assiste pas
non non non je n'ai pas les indices
passion d'ailleurs bientôt vous verrez
mon nom grand comme ça ça les a pas tant
mieux pour toi tant mieux pour toi ben
on regrettera mais tant pis si tu
réussis à hollywood ou du concours du
courage tu viendras me voir je vous
invite la coudraie amont mariaggi oui ça
sera mieux cérémonie superbe nous nous
unirons en grande pompe comme il se doit
pour des vedettes tout hollywood sera la
liste et local tony stone et les autres
en costume rituel du rituel oui oui
c'est pourquoi pas bon c'était une
possibilité
bah oui ça me surprend un peu ces gens
de tester les femmes seront voilées et
les hommes portant des turbans voilà oui
comme dans les films moins une coupe de
champagne comme ça le champagne non ça
suffit comme ça alors oui ah bah voilà
qu'est ce qui se passe ce qui est ben
est bas olala roule alors attention la
voyons voyons attention ou la wii voilà
je crois qu'il faut qu'elle se repose
moi j'ai l'impression qu'il faut qu'elle
se repose la malheureuse au label bio la
la la la la ça il ne faut jamais faire
des choses comme ça au s'énerve au moins
un petit peu de champagne et voilà le
résultat
oui oui tu crois qu'on les reverra t'on
vuitton culte pour tous quand à mon avis
tu sais son voyage aux etats unis son
mariage avec travolta
moi je n'y crois pas beaucoup à te
paraît louche ça me paraît bizarre vous
y croyez vous à cette affaire-là
moi j'ai l'impression qu'elle n'a pas
mis les pieds aux etats-unis d'une
impression qui m'est personnellement fin
on nous a dit des trucs qui paraissent
pas normaux n'avait rien remarqué tous
les deux mais non enfin elle nous a dit
au début chez à los angeles
et là j'ai vu
une antique monument elle a même le
culot clone de dire oui il y avait une
une cathédrale gothique du plus beau
style alors excusez moi mais les états
unis même un pays très neuf
il n'y a pas de monuments antiques il
n'ya pas non plus de grandes cathédrales
gothiques delà de la véritable l'époque
gothique ça c'est faux c'est absolument
impossible c'est un pays beaucoup trop
jeunes dont l'âge est offert ouah rien
d'autre quitte à choquer gothique louis
borloo type m'a un peu étonné par oui
tout de même ce n'est pas un pays
connecté et les femmes voilées à los
angeles les femmes voilées avec les les
hommes monture bande se rendre coûte
franchement nous nous mêlons pas bonne
at il ya des femmes voilées bat pas dans
les films peut-être dans leur ligne de
mire ou alors les véritables femmes
voilées on les trouve dans les pays
musulmans les trouve on a fait du non on
peut les trouver en arabie etc etc
dans le monde musulman aux etats unis
aux noms crois moi là nous a raconté
n'importe quoi
faut pas t'inquiéter elle restera avec
nous je te permets tu veux que je
retourne manipule un petit peu les
fourchettes là parce que je dois encore
voir si ça tient vraiment bien d'être en
même temps nos amis on se refaire une
petite idée de ce que c'était et
pourront jouer après ok ok alors c'est
ok pour que puisqu'on nous par
l'américain aujourd'hui on va pouvoir se
servir de cette affaire-là alors je
rappelle très propre mais comme ça sans
problème et la bouteille ça marche ça
tient à tous les sens simplement de
fourchette et un bouchon amusez vous
bien
et à très bientôt au revoir
[Musique]